[Música]
[Risas]
me ofende la palabra gordo
321 vamos
y
la razón por la que estoy aquí es porque
siento que la palabra gordo se ha usado
como un término ofensivo se han burlado
de nosotros por cómo nos vemos quisiera
tomar esa palabra y convertirla en algo
positivo algo como a alguien me dijo
gorda qué horrible pero responder si lo
soy entiendo cambiar la forma en la que
la percibimos muchas palabras que
deberían ofenderme no lo hacen creo que
es porque pienso no necesito que digan
la palabra para saber sus intenciones y
de sus intenciones si la usan para
lastimarme no me interesa qué palabra
usen me interesa que quieran lastimarme
supongo que no quiero que una sola
palabra tenga que tenga tanto poder no
no quiero que tenga tanto peso
ser de talla grande es una elección
321 vamos
[Música]
estoy aquí y no estoy muy en desacuerdo
porque algunas personas si intentan ser
de talla grande en la comunidad gay hay
personas a las que llaman débiles así
que muchos intentan ser más robustos
pero es decir no creo que sea del todo
una elección solo por eso no estoy muy
en desacuerdo
sí sí es cierto perdí 27 kilos en 6
meses todos estaban muy felices y yo me
odiaba odiaba cómo me veía odiaba lo que
hice porque me ejercité y todo eso así
que tome esa decisión porque pensé que
mis padres no me aceptarían o no les
agradaría mi comunidad de la comunidad
coreana estaría muy decepcionada porque
había una chica coreana gorda en el
mundo pero cambié de opinión y dije bien
no quiero entrenar tanto y odiar todo el
proceso para ser más delgada así que me
permitiré comer más que un cuarto de
taza de arroz blanco que estoy en
desacuerdo porque creo que la sociedad
en especial en eeuu
las personas están gordas solo porque
comen demasiado que solo nos sentamos en
casa somos holgazanes y no hacemos nada
y comemos hasta reventar pero no tienen
en cuenta a las personas que tienen
alguna enfermedad no tienen en cuenta
las personas que se ejercitan pero su
metabolismo no coopera hay muchos
factores pero el ciudadano promedio que
sólo sabe juzgar no tiene en cuenta eso
y albert no solo dicen ah eres gorda y
no haces nada pero me gustaría resaltar
que hay personas que si comen tanto que
llegan a ese punto luego te preguntas
por qué lo hicieron quizás un fuerte
trauma dificultad para lidiar con las
cosas hay muchos factores diferentes
para que las personas coman tanto que
lleguen a ese estado eso es justamente
lo que me pasó a mí no fue mi elección
no lo elegí solo me pasó
me han criticado por mi peso
321 vamos
vamos chicos
cuando regrese a corea que es donde
nacieron mis padres fue algo increíble
para mí pensé vaya me veo igual que
todos los demás este es mi país aquí se
supone que debo vivir pero no fue así
porque soy gorda mientras caminaba por
la calle las personas decían que tal
hacerte una liposucción no te quedarán
cicatrices porque lo harán bien aunque
son hacia domingos jueves incluso mi
familia me decía sabes que arreglemos
tus orejas tu nariz tus ojos tus labios
y dirás adiós a tu grasa y para mí era
inconcebible aceptar que me ofrecieran
eso que pensaran que odiaba a mi cuerpo
creo que de eso se trata te critican
creen que debes odiar tu cuerpo y ellos
pueden ayudarte creo que a todos los que
estamos aquí nos han criticado por
nuestro cuerpo el beso en realidad no
debería importar podría ser la chica más
delgada del mundo y habrá alguien que te
llame gorda si creen que esto solo
aplica para nosotros porque somos más
robustos o tenemos cuerpos diferentes no
a todos nos han criticado por nuestros
cuerpos las personas creen que tienen el
derecho a hablar contigo
poner su perspectiva sobre tu cuerpo
el hecho de tener rollitos en mi abdomen
o piernas gruesas no me hace menos
humana mi cuerpo no es de ellos no les
pedí su opinión es así
quiero perder peso
321 vamos
esta es difícil
[Música]
la mente
la razón por la que dude tanto es porque
amaré la forma en la que me veo sin
importar nada al mismo tiempo si
quisiera seguir bailando e ir al
gimnasio y todo eso y resulta que pierdo
peso eso estaría bien para mí me amo de
la forma que sea es lo que quiero decir
vamos quiero estar aquí porque de eso se
trata lo que hago creo que estar aquí
causará que causará que otros piensen o
digan ah no apoyas a los de talla grande
no apoyes a los activistas no quieres la
libertad pero eso solo tiene que ver
conmigo y con nadie más creo que si no
lo digo no seré sincero conmigo porque
pienso sabes que a veces pienso en
perder peso porque si lo hago todos lo
hacemos porque hay privilegios cuando
eres más delgado claro es natural pensar
ser más delgado porque habrá más
opciones para mí si eso pasa pero yo no
quiero perder peso
las personas delgadas tienen más
privilegios
321 vamos
te espera
para mí como bailarina es algo de verdad
muy molesto voy a audiciones y soy la
única persona de talla grande así van a
un concierto a ver a una artista nunca
verán a alguien que los que como yo como
bailarina de chris brown solo piensan a
los sexy vende y ser gordo no es sexy
pero si lo es y no pueden dejar de
pensar que ser delgado es lo mejor del
mundo y por qué no te colocas en la
línea de muy de acuerdo
de verdad no
es una decisión difícil el mundo lo
crearon con cuerpos delgados en mende
todo lo que está alrededor incluso las
sillas plegables los asientos en los
aviones o los asientos y espacios del
cine la triste verdad es que nosotros no
somos tan pequeños así que se podría
decir que las personas más delgadas
tienen más privilegios porque el mundo
está hecho a su medida tuve que
renunciar a mi carrera sólo por mi peso
obtuve un diploma en teatro y estaba
lista para ir a trabajar a broadway pero
en la universidad aumente unos 29 kilos
y no solo vi como los profesores perdían
su interés en mí los reclutadores
también perdían su interés en mí por eso
terminé como profesora porque quiero
enseñar que eso no está bien pueden
interpretar cualquier papel lo que me
parece gracioso es que vivimos en una
época en la que en el teatro podemos
aceptar el hecho de que los animales
hablen y esas cosas pero no podemos
aceptar que alguien se pueda enamorar de
una persona de talla grande si no se
trata de hairspray es el único papel que
nos dan y eso es muy molesto
amo mi cuerpo
321 vamos
amo a mi cuerpo pero me tomó mucho
tiempo hacerlo cuando me gradué de la
universidad y estaba en el mayor peso en
el que he estado en mi vida estaba tan
deprimida y molesta que ni siquiera soy
capaz de explicarlo luego cuando seguí
con mis estudios pensé algo debe cambiar
nueva ciudad nueva yo así que me
despertaba todas las mañanas y me miraba
en el espejo y pensaba que podría
gustarme de mí hoy y aprendí a amar amar
cada parte de mí porque es mi cuerpo me
suelten ese es mío y yo lo amo y si yo
no lo amo quién lo hará cómo te
mantienes así porque me tomó mucho
tiempo lograrlo ser de talla grande es
algo que ni amor ni odio es lo que hay y
me ha llevado hasta aquí claro que ha
sido un obstáculo pero lo he aceptado y
creo que cuando era más joven y les pasa
a muchos jóvenes ahora la gente decía
oye tu cuerpo o ama lo yo no hacía
ninguna estaba en el medio y llegas a
sentirte atascado y muy solo así que
pensar está bien
más tu cuerpo está bien si no estás
obsesionada con él solo sé amable
contigo y será suficiente si puede ser
amable con tu mejor amiga puede serlo
contigo por eso soy como soy todas las
mañanas al levantarme de la cama me miro
en el espejo y acarició mi pecho
acaricio mi abdomen muevo mi trasero y
acaricio mis piernas quiero darme quiero
darme amor a diario para mí es muy
importante darme un tiempo para pensar
me gusta mi cuerpo y lo que hace por mí
me gustaría cambiar a veces si lo haré
puede que sí puede que no pero al final
lo amaré como sea porque es un lugar
para mí y para mi alma somos un grupo
tel